good morning I'm Todd Mac over and I'm
the director of the fast festival for
earth science and technology in
celebration of MIT 150th anniversary
we've put together this whole festival
to show something about the very unusual
culture that combines the Arts and
Science and Technology at MIT and really
represents the creative and inventive
nature of this whole community
one of the agendas right from day one
was that the arts have been invisible at
MIT and that it was time to really
showcase who we were and what we do and
how experimental we are and the fact
that actually arts are engaged in
research at MIT we try to connect all of
the work that we do to science I mean
that's almost the starting point in our
thinking about many of the problems if
you have a music service you're making a
music iphone app or game or whatever
there's something you're going to use
with us we're kind of the big database
about music that power is quite a lot of
stuff that's out there right now I want
you to read me a poem oh you wouldn't
like my poems miss Richards please okay
I'll read this one
I have been in some box and I can still
sign
I'm very happy to be here and to be part
of this event it's really about a chain
reaction between the arts and the
sciences we know that music is
distributed across the brain that the
way it is unique in the brain can be
leveraged towards clinical goals but how
do you access that and the kind of
intervention where someone's empowered
one thing that rhythmic music does for
people is give them a way of chopping
time into it's a kind of instruction you
chop time into equal intervals with
equals substructures and so forth and
then you can see differences between
things Marvin has had an incredible
relationship with music and many of us
here believe that that has informed his
work in AI in interesting useful ways
oh very very is he around today there
you are I'm so glad to I haven't touched
your hand for god knows how long
the other thing about that piano that
everyone should appreciate is that
there's a person in this room who
succeeded in setting it on fire by
transcribing a score of xenakis that had
never actually had never been correctly
played I should make a confession which
is that everything Miller said this
morning is true and it's I did blow up
the booze and or fir by making it play
as an AA kiss at tempo
the thing that guitar hero and rockband
did was it made people not only kind of
experience kind of this this joy of
performing music and what it's like to
kind of be onstage and to sound awesome
but you also got to see how the music
was put together
you
if there's a lesson in all this which
make there is
for young people among
when you have opportunity
like that the
but the best
enrich your lives
enormously the memories were made
more vivid even more significant
why is to exploit the chance
you